taking the fight to the kidnappers these
officers of Nigeria special and two
robberies corresponding to a tip-off
that kidnappers have been cited at this
spot on the Abuja Kaduna highway the
thick forests nearby serves as a cover
for the guns
this highway has been a popular spot for
the kidnappers to attack potential
victims
the police say they're making gains
against the kidnappers
we recovered over 200 weapons videos
kaliba yes we show it to the whole world
even last two weeks we paraded about 79
kidnap suspects but bringing traffic on
the highway tells a different story this
was once one of the busiest highways in
the country the Abuja Kaduna highway
links the northern states of the country
to the other parts of Nigeria
now few motorists are brave enough to
travel on it many are choosing not to
drive and instead use the train yet even
on the trains armed escort is a must as
the kidnapping gangs get bold and more
sophisticated few places appear safe
Abdul Malik Mohammad a senior government
official was abducted from his home in
the city of Katrina then they begin to
say okay I should give them money I say
I don't have money they keep on asking
ah you have a big house we saw cars in
your house can't you sell those cars we
need money you have to give up money if
you don't give up money will kill you
after seven days in captivity Abdul
Malik was released after paying a ransom
but not before being told to deliver a
message to the authorities they give me
one that I should be able to tell the
government that most of them I only
point they are graduate they need
employment if they are not employed they
will keep on kidnapping people but it's
not just frustrated youth returning to
kidnapping it's now a free-for-all with
both petty and hardened criminals
joining in Reverend Adam Oberg who was
kidnapped and held in a forest by a
group armed with machetes
he says they tortured him until his
family paid a ransom of 200 dollars they
were drinking I said I want to give you
that
your life cause you know food for us to
get her safe judge so I received it in
our just hitting a cutlass were given at
the back of my my back
I'd hurry Cutlass one give me slap on
that it was it's willow until now
kidnappers in Nigeria targeted public
officials the relatives and foreign work
is often in the oil industry what is
worrying most Nigerians about the
current wave of kidnappings in their
country is that no one and nowhere feel
safe anymore
Hamad Al Jazeera on the Abuja Kaduna
highway